we could list more for next it would
have to be for Friday okay which is
doable yep okay you could do that on
right now right if you wanted to we want
okay Friday we have four packs left and
then we're sold
out let's
go NBA opening night so I have some NBA
cards
too
instram Friday there's only four four
packs left and then if you want to sell
anything on the spot to sh we we're live
okay do we have a
URL yeah I'll text it to
you I got you I got it for and we are
live ladies are we live gentl yeah
welcome everyone let's
Go's up chat everybody there it
is a good clap great we're live
on the gram live on Tik Tok we're
where's all my other stuff that's live
coming through those two what about what
about Facebook YouTube people are saying
no sounds on F what about LinkedIn
YouTube
Uno now you're good what do you mean now
I'm good I didn't even move it
all right what's good everybody Fanatics
live everybody on Tik Tok and Instagram
I can see you here I'm about to tweet
out the uh Fanatics live link I actually
think on Instagram my Fanatics live link
isn't my default um we are here we are
uh oh look at that I'm live right there
on Twitter that's pretty cool I like
that um let me do that over here uh
let's give away some free right
away why don't you explain there's a lot
of people here who are new we're waiting
audio Fanatics we'll explain a the audio
for Fanatics live is not not we're not
nobody can hear us no sound no sound on
Fanatics live currently it's uh on the
headphones button I don't know something
happen I'm not going all right give us
one second should it be
here says
headon Chad are we here are we alive you
remember you don't have to yell he
catches it no I know I'm excited you
know I get it doesn't sound like we're
back sound yes or no is there sound
yes but they said some there's no way if
they're not answering no way no not
getting s 27 I literally have the app I
can watch us they can't hear hm what's
happening something's
off um well we have sound here I'll uh
insta works perfectly and Tik Tok works
perfectly Tik Tok what is good
Instagram is good if you want to
get free you're going to go out on
the Fanatics Live app Tik Tok go to my
Instagram it's in my URL Instagram I
think it's in my URL Dustin's trying to
figure out it is okay so there it is you
can go to fanatic. live if you're on a
desktop fanatic. live if you are not in
the US on an iPhone let's do that all
right here we are we're here good so
there what's going on with sound not
sure all right figur it out figur it out
let me I'm going to Tweet out the link
to
Fanatics we are live without just
building the anticipation here I've got
to leave
shortly
um that's bad um hold on uh we will get
you all here uh Instagram great to see
you big big big love to all of you Tik
Tok you going to have to restart no just
going to do it off my computer I guess
okay but
like why are we doing it shitty don't
know so we can hear us now is there
anything with this or
no no sorry that's for a
light can you go back was it even on we
might be live again now now the audio
wait a minute no not yet there we'll be
able to hear it try it again is this
on everyone in what about hold on are we
on right now is this on right now I feel
like I hit it by acci no CU we'll be
able to hear on my phone if we're
live yeah well Instagram T giving them
extra time to download that's all we're
doing what do you mean it's the
mic
but is this the one that we always use
and so what happened it let the
about two weeks ago oh really
Swit
on the lives go to Instagram on the
profile download this app we'll see you
there in a second we'll get these free
gives aways
going in
there and
here okay so those are end Nows hello
hello not working what
about let me know if you want me to hit
up anyone from their side but I know you
know what's going on just have to be a
complete restart restart it hopefully
we'll be right back we should be able to
go right back in